you
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks very much Hadley and thank all of
you for coming to the conference I hope
I hope you had a great first few days
and great night last night it's it's a
great privilege for us at our studio to
be here with all of you this week so
today I'm going to talk about machine
learning with tensorflow and our for
those of you who don't know tensorflow
is an open source project from google it
actually came out just a little bit over
two years ago and from the day it came
out I have been excited about what we
could do with tensorflow
from our and for the last about 18
months me and some others at our studio
have been working on our interfaces to
tensorflow
and I'm really excited today to share a
lot of that work with all of you so I'm
gonna start by giving an introduction to
what kind of what is tensorflow what are
the core constituent parts of tensorflow
and how does it work at a kind of a low
level the principle application but by
no means the exclusive application of
tensorflow is for deep learning so I
want to talk a little bit incestuous
deep learning how does it work what is
it useful for not useful for and then I
want to get into the work we've done in
our to provide interfaces to tensorflow
for doing both deep learning and for
other kind of other types of machine
learning so let's start with what is
tensorflow and you might offhand just
say oh tensorflow that's a that's a deep
learning library it's it is that but
it's actually considerably more than
that tensorflow is actually a very
general purpose numerical computing
library and in our we've have a long
history of providing interfaces to
numerical computing libraries the
original s language was the motivator
for it was to provide interfaces to
Fortran numerical computing libraries
and today in R we wrap that code we wrap
code from glasses we wrap code from the
eigen C++ library the armadillo C++
library in our we love numerical
computing libraries and we love creating
lovely interfaces to them from our so
this is a new numerical computing
library and has some interesting
attributes first of all it's it's open
as I said before second of all it's
actually Hardware independent so a
tensorflow program can run equally well
on a cpu and take advantage of all the
cores on a CPU and that's actually using
the eigen and blast libraries that we
already use from our but it can also run
on a GPU or multiple GPUs and there's
even a thing that Google is created
called a TPU a tensor processing unit
which is hardware that it's designed to
run tensorflow programs and there will
actually be other instances of this in
the future so hardware independence is a
really cool attribute of tensorflow
another really cool attribute of it for
numerical computing is that supports
automatic differentiation and that
that's used extensively in the in the in
the deep learning parts of of tensorflow
the other thing is it was built from the
ground up for deployment and scalable
deployment so it supports distributed
execution it supports very very large
datasets so it's a really cool numerical
computing library that we can do a lot
of things with in our and that's kind of
the first bullet point of why our users
should care new numerical computing
library what can we do with it one of
the other cool things about it is that
there are many built-in optimization
algorithms that don't require that all
the data is in RAM so typically the
optimization algorithms we use require
that we manage to get the whole data set
in RAM but now we can have a 10 gigabyte
data set we actually feed data to models
just a small batch at a time and the
optimizer will work correctly so it lets
us do modeling and machine learning on
very large data sets without having to
have a huge amount of RAM another piece
of tensorflow that's interesting is that
when we typically we think about
building a model in our and then we want
to deploy it we actually need to bring
our code along with it in the deployment
but the whole design of tensorflow
is that when you build a tensor flow
model you can deploy it entirely
separate you don't need R or Python or
any other code it's just a C++ runtime
so this is actually really cool too so
the last piece I think we're really good
in are at writing interfaces to to all
kinds of things in computing and I think
we can do a lot of wonderful things with
our interfaces to tensorflow
so some the basics of tensorflow where
does that name tensor flow what are
tensors what's flowing just to give you
a baseline
of what we're talking about here before
we get into talking about deep learning
so tensors actually everyone here
already works with tensors pretty much
all the time
tensors are just multi-dimensional
arrays so in our the core data type
vector and matrices those are our
tensors so a one-dimensional tensor is
just an R vector a two-dimensional
tensor is an R matrix and then you get
into 3-d and 4-d arrays which are also
supports a zero D tensor is a scalar
which are does not have a scalar data
type but you can think of it
conceptually as a vector that's always
of length one so you're gonna be dealing
with tensors and the good news is we
already deal with tensors all the time
so there's really nothing new to learn
there I want to give some examples of
tensor data kind of how it plays out in
tensor flow and one of the things to
remember if you think about like a data
frame each row is an observation so
there's always a dimension that's
dedicated to observations or samples it
so in the case of a 2d tensor I can just
take a data frame turn into a matrix and
now I've got a 2d tensor that's
something we're all familiar with in our
time series data is our sequence data is
an example of a 3d tensor even though
sometimes that's represented in 2d you
can think of like a time series object
in R if you think about a time series
you're actually considering not just the
observations but what happens to the
observations over time so it's really a
3d entity that you're analyzing it's the
features the time steps and then
groupings of those image data is an
example of a 4d tensor again you might
think of an image as a 3d tensor you'd
say well it has height and width and
depth which is color channels like red
green and blue that's 3d but then if you
consider samples again you end up with a
for D tensor and similarly a video would
be like a 5 D tensor because it's
multiple frames multiple images so
that's kind of how tensors get end up
getting represented so what is this the
flow business that we're talking about
tensor flow programs are not just like
an R script that executes you actually
build up a data flow graph and what
happens is those tensors the data flows
through the graph and the operations in
the graph
and basically their operations in the
graph so an example of an operation
inside attentively graph is like a
matrix multiplication or the addition of
a bias term or taking gradients or
applying some kind of optimizer so those
are like functions that operate on the
data and it's and it's all put together
inside a graph and I'll kind of explain
why that's beneficial in a moment you
don't when you work with tensor flow you
don't actually program that you can
program the graph explicitly there's an
interfaces to do that but typically you
actually write much much higher level
code and I'm gonna explain this our code
in detail shortly but this is an example
of a model that I've written in R and
that's on the right what it actually
looks like as a tensor flow graph so the
graph is in when you're using high-level
api's two tensor flow is basically
generated and you don't have to reason
about it at the level of the graph but
the graph is still there and why is this
graph beneficial well we can actually
think of other examples that we that we
have in our of these sort of
intermediate representations so you can
think of like a shiny application when
you build inputs and outputs and
reactives you're actually creating a
graph and then shiny execute your graph
in a way that's kind of optimal and
efficient so the fact that shiny knows
the structure of your program allows it
to run your program in a way that's
really optimal and straightforward when
you write a deep liar code that works
against a database it generates sequel
sequel is sort of this intermediate
language that send fed to a sequel query
optimizer that then execute the query in
an efficient way so similarly what
Google wanted to do with tensorflow was
if we can get the representation of your
model or your program into a graph then
we can run it really fast so we can we
can run it in parallel we can run it
distributed we can look at the
operations in your graph and fuse them
together when when possible and then the
other thing is we can run this without R
or Python just with C++ so really the
the benefits of the graph are all about
this idea of portability performance and
scalability so the you know this does
create some indirection but I think it
has a lot of benefits so what are people
using tensorflow for I'm actually going
to talk about all of these in turn
they're all this
our tensorflow for our website a lot of
people are using it for deep learning
but people are also using it for a lot
of classical machine learning these are
some of the examples written up and
these are all like long-form blog posts
that get into things people are doing
but you can see some text classification
stuff some examples of trying to do
predictions on really noisy data there's
computer vision applications time series
applications and I think there's these
examples by actually hopeful and
confident the art community when given
access to this library is going to do
some really additional interesting
things that surprised us I have one
example of a project called Greta which
is similar in aims to bugs or Stan the
idea is to write statistical models and
fit them with MCMC and so the way Greta
works is I write a model statistical
model in our not in some kind of
separate specialized language and then
that model is compiled to tensorflow a
tensor flow graph and that actually uses
the art tensorflow package and the
benefit of this is a I'm writing an R
instead of a specialized language but B
because it's using tensor flow I can
train it on really large datasets I can
train it with GPUs I can actually deploy
the model so this is an example of
something that really has nothing to do
with deep learning that people have
already done with the art for tensor
flow interface and I'm hopeful that
there'll be more examples of this sort
of thing ok so now let's get into a
little bit of what because deep learning
is probably the main thing people do
with tensor flow and so I think it's
important to understand kind of what is
it what is it useful for what is it not
useful for should we in the art
community how much should we care about
it and kind of how does it work so I
want to cover some of that ground and
then I'll talk about the art interfaces
to tensor flow so at a really really
high level deep learning is taking some
input transforming it into some output
via successive layers of representation
when I say that's really abstract to say
input and output what I mean there's
like observations or X data and
predictions so it's X to Y but how do we
do that we do that by taking original
input in this case a grayscale image of
a handwritten number for
that's our input and our output is a
prediction about what the digit is the
number for we have to successfully
transform that input until we get close
to the output that's the basic mechanic
of how deep learning models work so I'm
talking about layers I showed four
layers there what exactly is a layer and
I'm not going to talk about the
mechanics of maybe some of you have seen
this before of you know neurons and how
they talk to other neurons and all that
stuff you can really just think of a
layer and all you really need to
consider a layer as it's a function it's
a data transformation function it does a
geometric transformation of data and
it's parameterize by a set of weights
and a bias just like a linear equation
so you can think of each one of these as
just a successive transformation of data
so that's all a deep learning model is
is taking some data and then piling
chaining together a bunch of
transformations of the data until we
actually get an output or in this case a
prediction so when I say representations
what am I talking about we really want
to take our data and transform it in a
way that's closer to the domain of
prediction that were that we're looking
for so this is a really simple example
I've got raw data I've got a bunch of
points and I want to determine whether
the point pretty able to predict whether
a point is black or white if I change
the coordinate system all of a sudden
the problem becomes really simple
because everything with X greater than
zero is a black point and everything
with X less than zero is a white point
so the idea is we want to transform our
data so it's easier and easier to get
close to the actual output that we're
looking for the prediction that we're
looking for if you work with
conventional machine learning models
you'll know this as sort of feature
engineering where we're trying to
transform our data into a form that
works better for the prediction tasks
and in deep learning the feature
engineering is actually done in the
layers it's the feature Engineering is
actually learned rather than hand hand
coded so back to this example of the
handwritten digits and I won't I'll
explain a little bit later how this
works but basically we're taking raw
data and we're trying to fill these
layers are trying to filter out
irrelevant information like how how the
image actually looks and it's trying to
find other things like where our edges
what are the angle of the edges and get
closer and closer to the
the output or prediction so it's you can
think of it as sort of an information
distillation pipeline and so this gives
us an intuition about where the word
deep comes from why do we call the steep
learning it's not because it gives us
deeper insight or deeper models it's
really just talking about this the fact
that there's multiple layers of
representation a traditional machine
learning model might have some feature
engineering and then one or two layers a
deep learning model could have 20 layers
or 30 layers or 100 layers and so maybe
a more accurate term for deep learning
might be like layered representation
learning or hierarchical representation
learning the deep learning maybe implies
more than it should but it's really just
talking about the stacking up of layers
and so what is this method achieved and
you can see from the list here it's done
really really well on a lot of
perceptual tasks like speech recognition
and image classification and then those
in turn have been composed together to
do things like trying to build
autonomous driving systems to build
reinforcement learning systems that play
games so it's achieved a lot this is
fairly straightforward mechanism and to
give you an intuition for why it might
be able to do that if you think about a
paper ball that's crumpled up and you
think about trying to write like write a
linear equation for how to UNCHR umple
the paper ball it would be really really
difficult to do that but if you
decompose the on it's a really complex
geometric transformation to UNCHR umple
that whole ball but if you decompose it
into a set of simpler geometric
transformations ie layers then it's
actually straightforward so human being
might just take that paper ball in in 30
or so it's really simple operations on
crumple it and that's really how deep
learning models work is that they learn
these simple geometric transformations
that compose together can do very very
complex transformations and therefore
solve a very complex functions or fit
very complex functions so why should we
care about this I actually think the the
domains that deep learning has proven to
perform well in are ones that are not
often of interest to our users so these
perceptual tasks like vision and speech
recognition
and these reinforcement learning
applications they're not things that
most our users are concerned with so it
may be that as in our user you think
it's cool that you can now do do state
of the art computer vision from our but
it's probably more interesting to say do
does deep learning provide improvements
on the techniques we have for our
traditional domains and is there data
that we analyze that has very complex
sequence or spatial dependencies that's
hard to model with traditional modeling
techniques is there data that requires a
huge amount of feature engineering
that's potentially brittle to model
effectively so I think it's more
interesting to think about our our is
deep learning applicable and how and
when to the things that we traditionally
I'll get into some examples of that and
a little bit but I think it's important
to note that it's definitely proven to
be effective at these perceptual tasks
but it's not yet proven that it's a
widespread benefit in other domains so
though certainly people are working hard
at it so I want to talk a little bit
about the mechanism of how these models
are trained what happens and and try to
convince you that this is actually a
pretty simple and straightforward
mechanism and it's actually kind of
surprising that it's able to solve the
kind of problems that it solves so I'll
start with a little bit of the basics of
how machine learning algorithms work and
then give you an example of kind of how
the training loop for a deep learning
model works so just to define some terms
the way machine learning algorithms
typically work is that you start out
with a bunch of data you have x and y
and you have a known Y and you basically
just feed batches of that data into the
model and the model basically
incrementally improves its coefficients
by examining the prediction saying how
close was the prediction to the actual
value and then adjusting the weights and
you know that the training process is a
sort of iterative training process that
takes advantage of a loss function to
evaluate the model and then tweak it
over time that's kind of how they work
there's their significant kind of
differences in orientation between
statistical modeling and machine
learning and I'm not going to go into a
lot of depth about that I have some
links here for you to take a look at but
I think one that you'll notice right
away is that oftentimes statistics is
focused on explanation and understanding
it's focused on kind of info
during the process by which data is
generated and machine learning really in
a lot of cases is exclusively concerned
with efficacy of prediction can we
predict things we don't need to explain
or understand the phenomena we just want
to predict it so as you're going to see
these deep learning models are complete
total black box models they they do
nothing to help you explain or
understand phenomena but they work well
for prediction so that's kind of where
that comes from that orientation comes
from so let's take a look at a model
this is actually and I'll again I showed
this before and I'll get into more
detail on this later here's the
definition of the layers of a model in R
and I'm get I'll get into what these are
a little bit later but there's different
types of layers I'm going to compose
them together and I'm gonna hope that I
can train this model to recognize
handwritten digits and there's an
example of kind of what the model is
going to learn throughout its gonna
learn these filters that help go from an
image into a prediction so how does that
actually happen so when a deep learning
model starts it has all these different
layers the layers have weights the
weights interestingly are randomly
initialized so in the model at inception
it literally has random weights so the
predictions and it makes our garbage
because the weights are random and so
what happens is that input is fed into
the model and predictions come out that
initially are wrong badly wrong but what
happens is that the predictions are
measured against the true known targets
and with a loss function so we get this
assessment of how good the predictions
were again initially there are quite bad
and what that what then happens is that
loss function is used to update the
weights and that is the job of an
optimizer and as I mentioned before
these optimizers can work with just
little batches of date 128 elements at a
time they don't require that all the
days in memory so we feed the data into
the model we find out how bad the
prediction is we use that to tweak the
weights and then we repeat that
thousands and thousands of times until
we have a model that performs in a
satisfactory way so the actual
mathematical mechanisms that work here
are really straightforward and the basic
mechanics of the whole thing are
straightforward and this tweet is
actually from the creator of the Charis
library and
he's making the point that there's
really nothing complicated going on here
but what happens is that once we take
this simple mechanism and we scale it up
it ends up looking like magic and we
return to this geometric interpretation
that we had earlier it's basically a
mathematical mechanism or machine for
taking really complex manifolds of high
dimensional data and on crumpling them
and the ideas behind this were actually
originated 30 years ago
we kind of knew about this we've known
about this for a a long long time and
until about 2012 it actually didn't work
very well in practice and I had the
trick the thing that changed is that it
turned out that we needed to be able to
have really really large models with
lots of big layers and train them on
lots and lots of data and so what
happened is that GPUs allowed us to
train much much larger models and the
internet allowed us to collect a lot
more data and that's kind of what
changed and made deep learning actually
work even though again it sort of was
invented conceptually 30 years ago so
what I mean by sufficiently large
parametric models this model I just
showed you the grayscale digit
recognizer that model has about 1.2
million coefficients or weights or
parameters and that's actually a pretty
straight grayscale digit recognition is
a lot easier than a lot of computer
vision tasks so this one has a 1.2
million parameters a bigger model that
can recognize all kinds of everyday
objects in color images here has about
138 million coefficients or parameters
so when we say sufficiently large that's
what we're talking about we're talking
about two potentially tens of millions
of parameters that need to be learned
and you can see why these models have
very little explanatory or ability to
help with your understanding because
you're going to get 138 million
parameters and how do you interpret that
so that's what I'm talking about and
that has made deep learning work very
well for computer vision and what's
happening now is that people are
beginning to apply it to other areas and
so as I mentioned natural language
processing but people are starting to
work on deep learning for time series
they're doing it for and biomedical
applications they're
doing it to create some novel approaches
to prediction in some other domains so I
want to talk a little bit about those
frontiers and kind of where they stand
and I think that illuminates a little
bit of what our posture toward this this
is in our so computer vision is kind of
the poster child for what deep learning
is accomplished there's a competition
that ran from 2010 to 2017 called the
image net challenge where machine
learning researchers tried to to build
models that would lay that would predict
what images are and the images were like
you know dog cat table chair so when
they started the competition in 2010 no
no entrance to use deep learning and
they had 71.8% prediction accuracy I
believe that was the best the best model
in that year in 2012 the very first team
that used deep learning entered the
competition entered the competition and
that team beat the rest of the field by
11 percent and that basically sat
ignited everybody to start looking at
deep learning for computer vision and by
the time we got to 2017 at a period of
seven years the accuracy and computer
vision went from seventy one point eight
percent to ninety seven point three
percent which is phenomenal that more
than anything got people excited about
about deep learning and they have
actually the competition isn't is not
going to exist anymore after 2017
because this particular task is
basically considered solved so that's
clearly it works really well in computer
vision and image classification and you
see a lot of applications for it there
people are also trying to apply it to
natural language processing and it's not
clear how good these techniques work
there's a lot of research going on so
the plot on the right shows the
percentage of papers at computational
linguistics conferences that use deep
learning kind of over the same timeframe
went from around 35% all the way up to
70% so again this could be it's a its
fad it's trendy everyone's trying to see
what they can find out but but if you
read this paper that I link to and these
slides are gonna be available after the
talk you'll see that people are making
progress in natural language processing
to do different things
clearly a lot of progress has been made
in language translation and I don't know
you may have seen this google has a new
neural machine translation system that
really significantly beats the
kind of state-of-the-art phrase based
translation and is approaching human
level language translation so that's
language translation but there's lots of
other things you want to do in natural
language processing again people are
starting to apply deep learning there
there's there are some interesting early
results but it's not proven that it's
going to completely revolutionize that
field similarly people are looking at
really complex timeseriesforecasting
problems this is a paper that actually
uses convolutional neural networks which
are the same kind of neural networks
that are used for images and so it's
looking for kind of spatial dependencies
that are invariant across the whole time
series so they're trying to use
techniques used for computer vision on
time series and in this case the data
sets they have missed paper they were
they were able to beat some some
benchmarks of conventional modeling but
I have not seen in time series again
it's not all of a sudden revolutionising
the field and you should always use deep
learning for time series that's on the
contrary I think there are certain types
of time series that it might work a lot
better for that's all that's really a
matter of exploration and research I
have one other time series example of a
whole different neural network
architecture that's used to before in
this case it's forecasting stock prices
so there's a bunch of articles like this
that you'll find and if you work with a
lot of time series data it might be
interesting to read these papers and see
what where deep learning is performing
well and where it's struggling there's a
lot of work going on in biomedical
applications and this could be
everything from patient treatment
patient classification to actual
fundamental biological processes this
paper just came out this month and it's
kind of a roundup of the work that's
going on there and I think they conclude
similarly we it's not there's not
evidence we're revolutionising this
field or these fields but there are
promising advances on the state of the
art worth paying attention to this is a
very very interesting example this paper
just got published this month and it was
a study that was done by Google Stanford
you have Chicago School of Medicine and
the University of California San
Francisco and they wanted to see if they
could provide better predictions about
patient outcomes based on electronic
health records and so what they pointed
out is that typically statistical models
electronic health records are really
messy they're uneven you know there's
different different
features in different patients the data
is collected in inconsistent ways
they're really messy so typically a huge
amount of effort is taken to select out
a bunch of features clean up and
normalize those features and the new
predictions using conventional machine
learning or statistical models but what
they point out in the paper is that when
you do that you're actually discarding a
huge amount of data all the data that
you all the features you excluded
because they weren't consistent or coded
consistently things like the the
handwritten notes of the physicians it's
all thrown out so they said what if we
did this what if we built a deep
learning model that considered the
entire medical record of every patient
including the physicians notes and
including the fields that are not
normalized against each other and see if
we could actually beat conventional
methods of doing prediction and in this
case they did find that they could be
state-of-the-art statistical models in a
bunch of categories I don't think it was
necessarily easy to get this result if
you look at the paper Jeff Dean is on
the paper he's like the inventor of
tensor flow he worked on this so I don't
know that anybody could just walk in and
get these kind of results but it's uh
but it's it's interesting that it's
possible it's a very very different
approach to prediction it's basically
saying that the feature normalization
and feature extraction is going to be
done by the layers of the deep learning
model not by kind of human reasoning
about the data and human composition of
like a sensible model we're just gonna
learn what the model is so this is a
really interesting paper to read this
again this just came out in the last I
think couple weeks there are quite a few
problems with deep learning models I've
alluded to some of these already the
fact that that their black boxes and you
can't interpret them you know excludes
their utility for a whole bunch of
things that we that we want to do with
statistics and machine learning and are
they can be brittle so there's if you
look up adversarial examples there's a
really classic one where you see like
two pictures of a panda and to the human
eye they look completely the same but
one panda has been like tweaked in
really subtle ways to yield to force the
model to have a totally different
prediction so you know they're people
are trying to overcome adversity are
examples with various techniques but
it's just important like a human being
can look at a panda and it just knows
it's something way way way more complex
go
for human being perceptual tasks these
models work but then they're brittle
they typically need a large amount of
data to perform well like I said we've
known about deep neural networks for 30
years and they didn't really work very
well until now so they typically need a
lot of data there are ways to transfer
knowledge from a model built on larger
amounts of data to a model that's
trained on smaller amounts of data so
there are ways to use deep learning for
smaller datasets but they typically need
a lot of data and they're very
computationally expensive to train as
well so this creates another problem
which i think is going to get worse and
be annoying to all of us
which is that there's a lot of hype
about deep learning there's actually a
lot of hype about like AI which as far
as I can tell means like I have AI have
an if-then statement so it's AI you know
it's it's it's awful and unfortunately
the the current tools for doing deep
learning models have become so good that
software engineers or even laypeople
with no training and modeling or
statistics can actually build these
models and they'll actually think that
they've built a model that's really
great they'll say oh look I've got you
know 84 percent accuracy I've built this
model I know nothing about modeling I
know nothing about statistics or there's
nothing about probability but here's a
model and it's deep so it's obviously
better than whatever whatever anybody
else has but but but typically you you
can't actually outperform traditional
statistical modeling techniques without
a lot of effort so usually these models
are going to be bad compared to the
models that we build and so we're gonna
have to deal with this and we're have to
patiently explain why well maybe that
model isn't the best one for us to use I
don't think this is reason for us to
throw up your hands and say just we
don't want anything to do with this I
think what we need to do is promote a
more balanced and knowledgeable and
nuanced dialogue about what these things
are good for and what they're not good
for because in spite of these problems
it's it does a lot of really useful
things you can actually this is a slide
that Google uses that shows from the how
many model description files which are
basically tensorflow models are sitting
in repositories all over Google and you
can see since the release of tensorflow
that is really accelerated across all
areas of the company so these models in
spite of their problems they're
brittleness their black box nature
can do super useful things so we want to
figure out what useful things they can
do for us in our and that kind of brings
me to what we've done in our to let you
use tensor flow and we actually have a
bunch of different interfaces high level
and low level we have some tools that
help you be more productive with kind of
your workflow and managing experiments
ways for you to easily use GPUs for
training and then hopefully an adequate
amount of learning resources so that you
can better understand how to use this
these tools in your own work so top
level we actually have three different
api's for tensor flow that one is the
Charis api which i'm going to talk quite
a bit about that's a very high level
interface for defining neural networks
the are code that I've showed you so far
has been from the Charis API there's
another API called the estimator API
which does more classic classifiers
regressors support vector machines
random forests kind of classic
statistical machine learning models for
tensorflow and then the core API is
actually what Greta used this gives you
full access to the entire computational
graph it's really good for like library
builders so not something I'm gonna I'm
actually not going to talk about the
estimator API or the core API much at
all this maps out into a suite of today
seven different art packages three for
the interface two tensorflow there's
this package for doing working with
large datasets called TF datasets and
then there's packages as I said
supporting tools for deployment for
managing experiments and then for
interfacing with Google Cloud ml and
I'll talk about their supporting tools
in a little bit so this is I've shown
you this code before this is the Charis
api high-level api for neural networks
and i will go into a lot more detail
about that in a minute the estimator API
gives you these high-level these almost
look like regular are modeling functions
really high levels they do a regression
to a classification Metron estimators is
about and then the core API is you
interacting directly with the graph here
you can see I'm like building the loss
function manually and I'm manually doing
the training loop so I don't recommend
people use this API unless they're
unless you're actually trying to build
tools for other people or do some novel
like Greta do something novel with
tensor
for our so let's talk a little bit about
Karis I'll give you an example and talk
about the different components of the
Karis API I wanted to make a little bit
of note about why Karis and actually
Karis is being at this point and all
over the last specially over the last
six months is being promoted by Google
as kind of the preferred interface to
tensorflow Karis works great for
end-user applications you can see this
on the left is the kind of Google search
for deep learning frameworks over the
last three or four years and you can see
that both tensorflow and carrots are
kind of pulling away from other
frameworks and on the right you can
actually see the use citation of deep
learning frameworks in research papers
and you can see while tensorflow kinda
has the most citations caris even though
it's really great high-level easy to use
api is also used quite a bit in research
so it you can go pretty deep with with
carrots as well so i want to walk
through kind of what Karis code and our
looks like and this is using that
eminent example again of hand of
handwritten digit recognize recognize
the first thing we do is is data
pre-processing and this really just has
to do with kind of reshaping and scaling
data into tensors you know you're almost
always going to be dealing with a lot of
times are matrices but you're gonna get
your data off of disk or off of whatever
what you know in from a data frame and
you're gonna turn it into tensors that's
the deep pre-processing step and then
you're gonna define your model so I've
shown this before this is the definition
of a model which basically says what are
my layers and how how are they going to
behave so that's the model definition
and then you're going to compile the
model which basically says what's the
lost function and optimizer that I want
to use during training and what metrics
do I want to collect during training so
this is really the heart of like making
a Karass model this define the layers
and compile it I want to make a quick
note about this second statement here
model compile you'll notice I do not
assign the the result of that expression
back to the model I'm actually modifying
the model in place
that's not conventional are typically in
our objects are by value you modify the
object and then you return a copy of it
that has the modifications but
Kerris models are these a cyclic graphs
of layers
they are stateful they get updated
during training I haven't shown this yet
but a layer can actually be repeated at
multiple places within the model so
these carrots models are by reference
objects and so the code you'll see when
we mutate them when we compiled them or
fit them is it's all done in place I
just wanted to make that clear because I
think when you see this code it's
different from maybe other our code that
you've seen so now training the training
process is done through the fit function
and we basically say here's our data and
in this case we're saying we're going to
feed 128 samples at a time to the model
we might have millions of samples or
just 120 at a time well we want to
traverse the input data set ten times
that's what epochs is again we're gonna
since we're gonna iteratively learn on
batches it's not enough to see the data
once we're gonna see it multiple times
and then as we're fitting we're gonna
hold out 20% of the data and use that to
validate that we're not just overfitting
to our data set we're not basically a
deep learning model can actually like to
just memorize the data and so it's
giving you a function that really isn't
useful cuz all it's done is memorized
the data set so we hold out data and we
test it against that to make sure we're
not just merely memorizing data so
that's what training looks like when
we're done with training you can see we
assigned back to a history object and we
can plot the history and see how the
training proceeded and how our accuracy
and loss improved or didn't improve
during training later we can evaluate
the model which is taking yet another
set of data that we've held out making
sure the model has never seen this data
and then we test to see how how good the
predictions are was the model really an
overfit to the data or does it
generalize well and then we can use
predict or predict classes to actually
generate predictions from the model so
actually want to show you a little bit
of what that looks like in our studio
this is a complete end-to-end
you know script I just showed you in
slides so again when we start well
though the damnest data sets actually
built in to Kharis so I get the data at
raw data in and then I'm going to turn
that data into some matrices that I'm
going to be able to feed into the model
you can see on the side now I've
reshaped the data into a bunch of
matrices
and then I define the model and then I
compile the model I can print a summary
of the model to see how many parameters
I have what the layers are and how they
work and finally I fit the model and as
the model is being fit you were gonna
actually show you the training metrics
in real time in our studio and this is
actually extremely useful because a lot
of times when you fit a model it you're
overfitting your accuracy is not
improving the model doesn't work and
it's really good to be able to visualize
that as you fit it so you can stop
training and say nope that that
architecture doesn't work those hyper
parameters don't work I need to try to
do something else I can also plot the
history and there's actually you can
actually get up the data frame behind
that if you wanna do various types of
custom custom visualizations of your
training history evaluate to see what my
accuracy looks like on data I haven't
seen before and then generate
predictions so that's that's just the
basic mechanic models can get more
complicated but some Kerris scripts are
really this simple that this is all you
do not to say that the task of actually
designing and building and getting the
model to work is simple a lot of times
it takes a huge amount of iteration so
layers is kind of the core construct in
Kerris and there's actually 65 different
layers available and you can create your
own layers this is just a sampling of
some of them I'm gonna talk
categorically about some of the types of
layers that there are there's dense
layers which are kind of the staple of
neural networks these are actually this
these work the same way that traditional
neural networks that were written about
and used in the 70s work and there are
kind of a staple of every every every
deep learning model usually if you're
using more sophisticated layers at the
end of the model you'll have these dense
layers and these dense layers are really
just like a bunch of weights and biases
that are applied and and cascade through
other dense layers convolutional layers
are used for computer vision most
commonly and they're basically abled
they're basically trying to find spatial
features and they're trying to find
spatial features that when they learn
like for example what an edges or what
an eyeball is that that knowledge is is
actually transferable to other parts of
the image so I see an eye and a certain
quadrant of the image and then I see
later on another
I in another quadrant I can still
recognize that as an eye so the reason
is convolutional we're building up these
filters that recognize patterns and they
were involving sliding the filter across
the entire image and you can see an
example of that here so again there's
better there's there's much better
explanations for how this works but you
can think of convolutional layers as
really good for image processing spatial
dependencies that sort of thing
recurrent layers are good basically
layers that have some memory or state
and so if you're dealing with sequence
data like time series data or text where
it matters not only what I'm seeing now
but what I've seen in the past
recurrent layers are able to maintain
state so they're often times used in in
these sequence oriented applications and
then embedding layers for those of you
who do natural language processing is a
way of vectorizing text so one way to
vectorize text would be to say I've got
an incidence of the word cat an instance
of the word dog and they're just classes
it's just cat versus dog but another way
would be I've got a vector that
represents semantic relationships
between words so in one of the
dimensions of that one of the axes of
that vector I've got a thing that says
Oh cat and dog are both animals so
embedding layers do this kind of
vectorization and you can actually learn
the embedding jointly with the building
the model or you can load a pre trained
word embedding like that we
conventionally use like word Tyvek you
can load one of those embeddings into an
embedding layer so there's just a few of
the layer types but there's again
there's sixty-five layers and a lot of
what doing deep learning is is trying to
figure out what there's the right
composition of those layers and behavior
of those layers to get a model that
works well so in Kerris once we define
our layers we compile the model and what
is that really what the compilation of a
model is really converting the layers
into a tensor flow graph and then
applying the lost function and optimizer
to those that's what a cop that's what
compiled the compile step really does
there are a wide variety of loss
functions available in Carris and you
can actually write your own loss
functions so depending on what you're
doing you'll use maybe a custom loss or
maybe one of the built-in losses or more
than one of the built in losses there
are many optimizers that are built in
again these optimizers don't require
that
all the memory is in RAM there are many
metrics built in you can write your own
metrics so these are ways of assessing
how the model is training how its
behaving how well it's doing all this is
summarized in a cheat sheet that we have
don't worry about copying this URL down
because I'm going to share the link to
these slides and this is available from
the 1004 our website but that this cheat
sheet kind of goes through a lot of the
same content that I just went through
but I think actually is a much more
clear treatment it's really excellent so
I wanted to go on and talk about some
examples that we've written up of using
our the arc Harris API to do deep
learning these are all available on this
gallery page of our tensorflow for our
website and each one of these is a blog
post that writes up in detail kind of
the motivation what we did what worked
what didn't work intermediate data
visualizations so a really good way of
exploring these different use cases the
first one actually demonstrates how to
do what I mentioned earlier transfer
learning where you hear we're basically
gonna try to predict whether an image is
a cat or a dog and we're only gonna
train on 2,000 input images and the way
that's gonna work is that we're gonna
use a model that was already built that
that knows about edges and things
related to identifying things like cats
and dogs we're gonna transfer the
knowledge of that model into our new
model so this is an example of using
deep learning with a smaller data set
there's another example that talks about
timeseriesforecasting of weather
temperature temperature data and it
talks about different techniques for
different eggs you can try to make a
time series model perform better
including stacking up multiple current
layers together bi-directional recurrent
layers which look at both both temporal
orders of data so this is a good kind of
introductory primer to doing time series
there's a really cool example we have
where we're trying to for cancer
immunotherapy classify peptides to
figure out how they're gonna bind if
they're if they're reintroduced and this
is using deep learning we show the same
classification tasks with a random
forest and
with a simple feed-forward neural
network and it's a really good
introduction to how you might use deep
learning with with this sort of data
another example is looking for credit
card fraud and what's interesting about
this is that you've got I think
something like half a million
transactions and only like two thousand
of two thousand of the transactions are
fraudulent so this is a way of trying to
find signal in those two thousand
examples of fraudulent transactions and
be able to still get good good
predictive accuracy even though we don't
have that much data to train on so
that's that is this is a text
classification example which says we've
got questions from Chora are they
duplicates or not it's based on a kegel
data set one of the interesting things
about this we also show how to create a
shiny application that's a front-end for
this model it's actually quite
straightforward to do that and this
gives you a sort of simple introduction
to doing that another example is using
deep learning to predict customer churn
and this also demonstrates a couple
other interesting things one of which is
the line package which I'll talk about
in a minute which is a way of it's not a
way to understand how the model works
but it's a way to understand for
individual prediction what features
contributed to that prediction so that
line package is demonstrated here and we
also demonstrate again building a shiny
application on top of a deep learning
model
another example is learning word
embeddings from Amazon reviews so this
is we've got think these are the fine
food reviews data set from Amazon and
we're trying to figure out what words
are semantically similar so there's just
a plot of some of the it ends up being a
multi-dimensional embedding but this is
an example of doing word embeddings
couple examples about addressing explain
ability because again while you know 138
million parameter model looking at it
doesn't tell you anything about the
phenomena it is actually possible
oftentimes to understand why a given
prediction was made by a neural network
here's an example of we're classifying
images and we've predicted that this
image is an African elephant and
actually by inspecting the gradients of
the intermediate
lairs it's possible to pull out a heat
map that says these are the parts of the
image that that most caused us to do
this classification so then we juxtapose
the heat map over the original image and
we actually see this is why the model
these are the things that contribute to
the model saying that this was an
African elephant and then similarly lime
which allows you to take an individual
prediction and say what features
contributed to that to that prediction
so there is work going on in explain
ability of predictions it's not the same
thing as I look at the model and it
explains the phenomena but a lot of
these models are going to be used if
they're being used for things like
patient care or making recommendations
about surgical procedures or approving
or denying loans they have to be
explainable we have to be able to say
this is what we have a machine learning
algorithm but this is why the machine
learning algorithm is coming out the way
it is so kind of coming back to this
idea of frontiers many fields have a
deep learning frontier that is not yet
reached or even well approached and in
most of these cases the traditional
statistical modeling and machine
learning methods are cheaper and more
accurate so it's really pretty as once
you get out of computer vision and
language translation a lot of this stuff
is in is in the research stage it's in
the speculative stage and I think
there's different approaches you could
take to that you know right now crew
creating an image classifier that has a
super high accuracy is this completely
trivial so that field that frontier is
explored and understood and applicable
but in other cases the frontier is far
away and you could so you can wait and
see wait wait till okay I do this type
of timeseriesforecasting it's not proven
that deep learning helps me I'll just
wait and sit until it is proven and then
I'll apply it then another approach
could be to try to see what contemporary
research is doing see what people you
know both formal research and what
people are publishing on the web and
evaluate that and try that with your
data and your work and see if it see if
it improves things and yet another
approach is to actually try to in your
field of endeavor try to approach the
frontier trying to see if you can find
novel applications for for deep neural
nets so all of this requires you know
it's great to show examples that do
interesting things but it does require a
lot of work and tie
patience and iteration to get these
models to work well so in practice
there's a huge amount of experimentation
that's done with model architecture with
hyper parameters and what happens is
people gain better intuition about what
sorts of models and layers and other
things work well for the class of data
problems that they have so it tends to
require a lot of iteration it tends to
require a lot of compute power and it
sort of tends to require some related
tools to help you kind of streamline
your workflow and make the most of the
compute power you have and that's kind
of the next piece that I want to talk
about is the tools that we've built to
help you with the process kind of first
and foremost is using GPUs some deep
learning models work great on CPUs ones
that use convolution or recurrent neural
networks tend to be very slow on CPUs so
if you go to our tensile VOC tensorflow
for our website there's a bunch of
resources about different ways you can
use GPUs one is if you have a high-end
Nvidia graphics card you can do use a
GPU on your local system
there's cloud services that let you do
batch jobs that use GPUs you can set up
a cloud server with our Studio server on
Google compute or Amazon or Azure and
there's even ways to actually have a
virtual cloud Linux desktop that has a
GPU so all that's covered on our GPU
page I won't talk about that further but
it's definitely something to look into
if you want to explore we have another
package called TF runs stands for
tensorflow runs and the idea here is
that because a huge amount of
experimentation is required with deep
learning models you're gonna run a ton
of training jobs instead of using the
source function to run those jobs use
the function called training run and
what training run does is it records
everything about that job the source
code the output the performance of the
model the hyper parameters are used for
the model and then you basically have a
data frame at the end for all the model
runs that you've ever done and then you
can compute on that data frame to try to
understand better what's working well
and not working well it also gives you
reports on each runs that summarize
again the code the model the metrics the
performance of the model so every single
time you do a training run one of these
reports is generated and then you can
compare
so if you find okay I've examined my
data frame I found that these are the my
best to performing models what was
different about them and you can see in
this case that's showing a source code
diff saying I changed two things in the
source code and that accounts for that
difference in performance there's
another piece called flags which
basically says if there's important
aspects of my model it's good to
externalize those get them out of my
source code so that I can kind of pass
these flags to my script as a parameter
so you can see I'm defining a set of
flags here and then I'm using the flags
when I define a layer and then when I
train the model I'm passing one of the
flags they're basically kind of command
line parameters for your script that'll
you easily vary things and then that in
turn enables this this construct called
a tuning run that says okay I've got two
types of dropout I want to vary in this
case I want to vary dropout from 0.2 to
0.4 and I want you to try every
combination of those two hyper
parameters and then tell me what the
best model is and if the number of
combinations gets very very large you
know into the thousands then you can
actually sample from that and you know
and only run you know 50 training jobs
to rather than thousands of them to try
to evaluate what the best model is but
these sort of tools end up being
critical to getting deep learning models
that Performa because you have to try so
many different things the cloud ml
package is an our interface to Google
Cloud ml and Google Cloud ml basically
lets you train models sort of you sort
of submit batch jobs to cloud ml and
then the model trains and what's really
cool about it is that they have GPUs and
they actually have some really really
fast GPUs and even machines that have
multiple fast GPUs available and they
also have a service for doing this this
hyper parameter tuning and I just talked
about so the idea is you want to work on
the from the comfort of your laptop with
smaller downsampled data and then when
you want to actually do your training
that's going to take three hours you
submit it to cloud ml then it takes 20
minutes hopefully instead of three hours
similar to training run there's a
function called cloud ml train and when
you give an R script to cloud ml train
it will actually upload the contents of
the working directory to cloud ml it
will actually figure out what packages
you're using and make sure those
packages are installed on the cloud
email server and then when I do this I
can actually specify the kind of
hardware I want to use so in this case
I'm saying use a standard GPU in this
case I'm saying use like super pumped up
latest and greatest nvidia tesla GPU and
then you kind of similarly once you do a
training job you can collect the results
you can get all the files that were
generated and get a report about how it
did you can see all your jobs in a data
frame and then once if you're using
these flags that i talked about you can
actually do hyper parameter tuning so in
this case I've defined my flags and I've
used them in defining kind of composing
my model and I can write a yamo file
that I give to cloud ml and I can say
here's the parameters here's how I want
to vary them and here's the metric that
I'm trying to optimize for in this case
it's validation accuracy and here's how
many trials I want to run so this is a
way to search over huge spaces of models
and it's all done remotely in the cloud
and you kind of just only charged for
the the compute that you use in the
execution of those jobs so when the job
is done you get a summary of all the
jobs what the flags were and what the
what the accuracy was just you can
figure out what how your what
architecture and hyper parameters work
best for your model we I talked a little
bit earlier about how tensorflow models
can be deployed without an hour runtime
dependency so the TF deploy package has
tools that facilitate doing that I won't
get into all the mother talk about this
and the Interop session one that will go
into more detail about this but the idea
is you get a model you export it and
then you can for example serve that
model using at rest a breast HTTP API
you can serve it using an open source
project that Google has called
tensorflow serving you can serve it from
our studio konnekt you can serve it from
cloud ml so these models the nice thing
is these models can be served from a
whole wide variety of different sources
and again there's no our runtime
dependency for serving the model
it's very easy to embed these models
inside shiny applications a couple
examples of that on the gallery and then
what's really cool is you can actually
deploy these models not just to servers
but you can deploy them to embedded
devices you can employ them to mobile
phones you can actually deploy them into
the browser there's a library called
Kerris j/s and a library called deep
learning j/s that lets you take
tensorflow and caris models and run them
directly in JavaScript so this idea that
the model is this graph that's
independent of the programming language
used to create it is a really really
powerful one and I think hopefully one
that we can take great advantage of in
our again there's a talk talking about
deployment and Interop session so what
are the big big takeaways I hope you
internalize a little bit from this talk
one is think of tensorflow
not just as a library that people use
for deep learning it is a
general-purpose computing library and it
has lots to offer us and we should be
exploring those things like what has
been done with the grete project deep
learning has made a lot of great
progress in some fields and a lot of
people are working hard at at making
progress in other fields and it's likely
to increase in importance in those
fields it's hard to say exactly how much
but I think it's something that a lot of
people are working on it's going to be
relevant to our work and I think most
importantly the work that we've done for
the tensorflow
our interfaces we have a great set of
high-level api's different levels we
have high level and low level so doing
deep learning in R is now really easy
and you have the state-of-the-art tools
you have the tools that are used by
researchers and practitioners the best
tools used by researchers and
practitioners today and we have
low-level interfaces for doing more
innovative things there are a couple
more talks in the interrupt track at
11:00 there's a talk from Michael Quinn
who's from Google and he's going to talk
about modeling predictions on Google
store data using the tools that we
talked about today and then we have this
deployment talk that comes immediately
after that so check those out if you're
interested there's a website that we
have tensorflow at our studio comm that
really has a lot of the content that I
covered in this talk obviously much
deeper
web site covers kind of everything you
need to know about tensorflow and our
and I this is actually really important
if you want to get into this I there are
two books that I highly recommend that
you read they're very different books
one is this book deep learning with
Arthur just came out a couple days ago
and my name's on the cover but I didn't
write any of the prose in the book I
just that it's written by the Francois
who's the gentleman who created Karis
and I took his his book his Karras book
which covers the Python interface and I
worked worked with him to adapt it to
our so this is a book that really covers
the concepts behind deep learning mostly
it's a conceptual book but all of the
examples are done in our using the
Charis interface there's actually no
math in this book at all it's all of the
mathematical intuition is provided by
showing you our code so that's one book
great conceptual introduction all code
no math the other book is kind of the
most important book I think right now in
the field sort of providing the
conceptual foundation for deep learning
this book has no code at all it's all
math so so depending on how you learn
and how you like to approach things read
one or the other first but these are
very different books but I think they're
both they're both essential so thank you
very much these slides are available at
the URL displayed here and the other
thing I would urge you to do is if
you're interested in this stuff on our
tensorflow for our blog we're posting
new examples and case studies all the
time so if you want to kind of keep up
with the work that we're doing and other
people are doing subscribing to that
blog is a great way to do that so thanks
very much and I'd love to hear what
questions people have
[Applause]
you
[Music]